these machines were complex enough that
you could use them as the way we use
machines now I had word processes test
up publishers and use them for also
things but they were still simple enough
that one person could understand not
just the software and how to write
programs but actually how the hardware
would work as well one thing you may
have noticed the screen is we have these
huge borders around the edge of the
screen and the way the hardware's
designed is that you've got these
borders suspect these are probably there
because your televisions at the time
would what was called over scam so that
some of the image will be hidden behind
the edges of the screen so you leave the
border so you could see everything on
the screen but it meant that you only
have this small section that you can
actually draw into that was until the
programmers came along so I'm changing
the software again so there's not mine
this is something for a group in
Luxembourg and what we've got here is
what was called the demo scene so the
demo scene was young teenagers early
twenties type people and paps older I
wasn't really involved with it much he
would write this software and would then
share it among their friends not on the
Internet as we do now because at this
point that was still limited to
academics really but actually through
things called bulletin boards where you
died look your modem on your computer to
another one and copy the software off or
even just sharing floppy disks in the
playground so I'll turn the sound down
now if you look we've got graphics all
over the screen and I said the machine
was designed to only display in the
border what's going on here well lots of
people when they've started a program
this thing people began to realize that
by understanding how the hardware worked
and they knew how their software work
that they could trick the hardware into
drawing graphics in the border it's
actually quite a clever thing because it
relies on the fact that when you design
hardware you want to do the simplest
harder implementation as possible so
that you don't have to use any more
transistors in the silicon then you have
to so all old CRTs you draw each line
separately one after the other across
the screen so on a power screen you've
got 625 lines and in image but because
of the way video systems work
you get to what are called fields of
about 312 lines each so as far as your
attire is concerned each image that it
shows is 50 of them a second is 312
lines high the hardware inside is
counting each of those lines every time
it starts a new line the hardware's
counting it says in the hardware I'm at
lying
whatever it is start showing the display
then it comes down to a matte line 200
and something stop showing the display
what people realize that this is
slightly different for the American
system these machines could work both in
the UK in the US and anywhere else in
the world if they switched it from being
a UK machine to a u.s. machine it just
the right point in terms of the video
frequencies the harder would say well
I'm a UK machine so they have to do
anything here then a bit later on I
would say I'm a u.s. machine I don't
need to stop the display here and it
would carry on displaying graphics into
the boards and so by some very very
clever programming switching things on
and off literally counting exactly how
long each instruction the CPU takes so
that things can be turned on and off in
the hardware exactly the right point
they were able to get graphics into the
whole display there and it was really
nice for a programmer that you could
understand everything that was going on
and program it so they had to try saying
yeah they hacked it they not so much as
that they pushed it beyond what the
designers intended it to do they
understood what the designs are done and
then changed it and you saw this with
other computers people did it with the
Commodore 64 as well another things
that's the programmers push the machines
further than people expected it's easy
to do these sort of graphical effects
for a demo like this but it's much
harder to do things like full screen in
the middle of a game and so often the
games would still have smaller displays
and so on and in fact one of the slight
issues with the original design of the
machine before the enhancement is that
the CPU didn't quite have enough time to
be able to smoothly scroll the screen
like you would see on perhaps on
something like the Commodore 64 or the
Amiga which was also popular at the time
and so people had to perhaps reduce the
size of the screen slightly or come up
with clever programming tricks
to be able to do some lights there was
really a machine that the program was
enjoyed because they had to think clever
to work out how to program things there
was a several versions of the Atari ST
created the earlier ones are pretty much
the same hardware just in different
configurations so we had the TV
modulator added to therm you had the
floppy disk adding two others this one
was actually rebranded the Atari mega or
the Atari ST depending on which model
you got and they put it into the sort of
classic three box design T on a separate
keyboard your base unit with your floppy
drive in and the CPU this monitor here
is actually the high resolution monitor
it runs at 72 Hertz as opposed to 60 or
50 Hertz which most computers at the
time worked and I would still say it's
one of the crispest monitors I've ever
worked with certainly only the retina
displays on the Mac come any closer the
4k monitors come any closer to the sort
of crispness that you get on it was
absolutely wonderful
to work off because it sends the camera
funny strobing at 72 Hertz the floppy
drive on this machine was borrowed for
Alex's floppy disc Orchestra you can see
that in one of the early computer file
videos which is linked here so I've
replaced it with a standard was actually
from a spark blade from an ultra spark
so it actually still works it's so I can
use the machine we don't have the STM
model which we've seen which added sort
of better graphic support support for
things like Hardware scrolling better
sound it could do 8-bit DMA sampled
sounds opposed to the sound chip that
was in there so you could do better
sounds still not up to the standards
that you'd get with a MIDI keyboard but
it was better for games and things
although very few actually used it at
all well then produced two machines one
of which I haven't got here
oh this at home was the Atari TT which
had 68030 precedent so it's much more
powerful he could run things like UNIX
and was designed for sort of the
workstation market but it's also
compatible with the Atari stuff but more
the serious software compared to sort of
the games end of market they also
produce this version which is a slightly
faster version of the Atari mega STA
again it's in the three box design
separate keyboard
is actually a 2d keyboard from Sweden
which you can still get as a spare part
on eBay even their Atari is long gone I
actually really like this design you
sort of refer to as the wedding cake
design whether it's quite probably the
nicest one I designed the last computer
then the Atari designed again in the
esti family is this one the atari falcon
it's a bit of a hodgepodge of a design
but it's got much better graphic support
much better sound in there so a 16-bit
sound it's also got what's called a DSP
chip which was probably put in there to
do audio processing but people have used
it to do 3d texture mapping and all
sorts of things people have putted doom
to run on it and there's someone even
trying to get bits of quake to render on
there at a reasonable frame rate that
was the last machine entirely produced
before they left the computer industry
to develop the Jaguar games console one
thing that's perhaps surprising at that
time not so much now when laptops are
common but it's Harley did produce two
portable versions of the ST the first
one which was called the Stasi
really was a portable luggable machine
it had a LCD display it was basically a
mega ste with an LCD display bolted onto
the back and was huge heavy and needed
mains power but it was useful musicians
gigging out on stage they could take it
and plug it much easier than a full
system the second one about 91 was a
sort of hotchpotch with the Atari ST a
which was called the St book much
thinner much lighter long battery life
and so on really quite powerful but
hardly solid I think less than a
thousand were actually made however one
interesting thing is as well as
developing that they also developed
alongside it the St pad which was a
tablet similar in the idea to something
like the iPad but this is back in 1991
so had a stylist you could interact with
the operating system it was never
released and never to be but it's
interesting to think could the tablet
revolution have happened 20 years
earlier
we put these chips in the BBC micro and
none of them worked and we never knew
why which of course means that we didn't
know why the national semiconductor one
did work right and a million and a half
BBC micros later it was still working
and I still didn't know why